okay Johnny you spend a lot of time
London you can do is this a kind of home
from home no you asked the question and
you said no it's sort of a no yes
really yeah I end up here about working
yeah yeah yeah a lot of location stuff
here well you're very welcome thank you
very much I was trying to get the you
know the the sir thing you know
oh yes sir Johnny Depp have you met any
royalty along the way yeah I did yeah
yeah Prince Charles and the other one
that one came to the the premiere of
Finding Neverland okay yeah
and uh sort of shook his hand and he was
sort of Ohio rather I don't understand a
word he said and I don't think he
understood the word I said so it wasn't
very meaningful necessary and that one
seemed nice I think the knighthoods in
the Pope the weird thing is where cuz
you know when you search online for
people who've taken selfies and stuff
with their with your good self Johnny
Depp it seems it's not that hard to look
like Johnny Depp and this is just these
are just this looks that's a poem I'm
gonna wait here's some people out for
the night oh my god
instead of a hot dog
as long as she's happy she's happy she's
very she's very happy
and obviously you're here to talk about
a black mass which is terrific and the
thing is in Boston when you were there
it must have be caused a sensation but
then double the chaos because benedict
cumberbatch
wherever you go you have very ardent
fans orgrim he said I do do by the
medium of his jenandtony code I do yes
and somebody saw a Benedict on location
in Boston and we've got a picture of you
on set that day and so she she saw
Benedict and immediately rushed home and
went on to read it and she goes um I saw
a Boston batch cuz that's your name in
Boston it's an adaptable son yes I
suppose about this morning bury me in a
y-shaped coffin for I am deaded so she's
right [ __ ] he is fine
he was wearing a blue hat a dark blue
polo shirt the gray pants and the white
shoes he's taller than I thought
I suspected he was about 511 want to be
six foot of a nub six foot tall and
ripped like her really much more muscly
than I was expecting those arms dad ass
and the arm veins were in full effect
popping there's not an ounce of fat on
that man it's all muscle
sinuan wholesome goodness and the hat
looks better in real life too but the
last one with the hair you know the
paragraph the last paragraph is though
where you just go pick whoa
I couldn't smell him I really tried
he was so close that had he been wearing
Cologne I think I would have been able
to tell just the lightest cumber musk in
the bottle
I'm asking your general direction I
gather tonight well I can I can finally
admit that I wrote that
parents are the ones who are slowly
dying and to be able to bring a smile